égalité de traitement pour l'école libre
et pour l'école publique de la part de
l'état telle est le sens de la loi sur
l'enseignement privé la loi guermeur du
nom de son auteur député rpr du
finistère le texte déjà adopté par les
députés en juin dernier a été adopté
définitivement aujourd'hui par les
sénateurs 174 voix contre 104 et sans
modification du texte
je rappelle que l'école privée l'école
libre compte deux millions d'élèves soit
20% des effectifs scolaires jakin
collins cette loi qui a été votée par
l'assemblée le 29 juin dernier complète
et actualise la loi debré de 1959
elle prévoit la participation au
financement des écoles privées
l'aide de l'état qui concernait jusqu'à
maintenant uniquement les salaires des
professeurs et les frais de
fonctionnement des écoles s'étendra
désormais à l'équipement et à la
construction par exemple la construction
des ateliers de technologie rendu
nécessaire par la réforme haby les
statuts des maîtres du privé seront
alignés sur ceux du public âge de la
retraite droit à la formation continue
et cetera pour sauvegarder leur
indépendance la nomination des maîtres
restera la seule responsabilité des
chefs d'établissement et non des
recteurs
ceci pour éviter que des maîtres nommé
de l'extérieur n'est pas les mêmes
convictions que l'école est détruit
ainsi de fait le caractère propre et
notamment religieux d'un établissement
l'enseignement privé gardera la
possibilité de former ses propres
enseignants dans des centres privés
enfin la gestion des établissements sous
contrat restera autonome sous contrôle
évidemment mais sans main mise de l'état
c'est donc une loi qui a été très
minutieusement préparée dans le calme
pas du tout une loi électoralistes en la
loi que nous voulons n'est pas pour
détruire l'école publique bien au
contraire j'ai passé moi même mon
certificat d'études à l'école publique
c'est vous dire que je n'ai rien contre
l'enseignement public non c'est une loi
qui a fait une loi de justice sociale
pour les maîtres qui sont cent mille
cent mille travailleurs à qui on va
donner l'égalité avec leurs collègues de
l'enseignement public
c'est aussi une loi de liberté pour les
familles qui doivent pouvoir choisir en
fonction de leurs convictions
l'éducation de leurs enfants sans avoir
à payer plus pour cela que s'ils
envoyaient leurs
enfants dans l'enseignement public et
puis c'est une loi de sécurité pour les
écoles que l'on ne pourra plus
nationalisée dans l'ombre sur un simple
morceau de papier mais qui sera protégé
contre les atteintes aussi bien de
l'extérieur que de l'intérieur et je
crois qu'au fond on peut dire que cette
loi fait respecter le contrat moral qui
est passé au sein de la communauté
éducative c'est à dire entre les maîtres
les parents et les élèves et je crois
que c'est ça la liberté